Korea had no future at their current
fertility rate right now for every 100
Koreans there will be 5.9
great-grandchildren we are looking at a
94 population collapse over the next
century
why have you been in the news so much
recently
because I am calling out that the
they think a lot of people have
mentioned collapsing fertility rates
before
um but I I think that no one has really
so consistently uh uh brought it up in a
way that the people who want to ignore
it have to look at the problem you know
when I pointed out because I think a lot
of people especially you know on the
more Progressive side of the spectrum
they just want to dismiss it oh the
planet's better without humans or
whatever but when you point out that not
a single Society on Earth today except
for maybe Israel we can talk about that
later in the conversation has figured
out how to have Prosperity gender
equality and high levels of education
and anywhere close to a stable
population like considering we are
trying our best and I think rightfully
so to spread those things across the
world that should be like a note like
that should be like a oh this system
that we think is so great and we want to
be the future of human civilization
doesn't seem to work at at the most
basic level
that seems like quite a scary uh
proselytization for the future or
prediction for the future if you're to
say that we need to get rid of one from
education equality prosperity
or birth rate we just need to concede
the fact of the birth rate what we need
to do is we need to find new cultural
Solutions we need to find a way to
maintain fertility rates while having
education while having gender equality
and while having a high level of
prosperity and there are many places we
can look in the world today to begin to
get inspiration for how we might do that
you know I think um to understand the
scale of the threat right now one of the
the things I always start people with is
when I started caring about this and a
lot of people are like why is it that
people in Silicon Valley seem to care
about this so much and it's because
there's a lot of VCS in Silicon Valley
and VCS need to chart the economy 50 100
years in the future in the way that you
know Wall Street people really don't
they're looking at the economy five ten
years out or whatever so because of that
when I was working as a VC I happened to
be working in Korea when I was working
in a VC
um and I kept trying to chart the future
of the economy and I kept coming to the
same answer is it Korea had no future at
their current fertility rate right now
for every 100 Koreans there will be 5.9
great-grandchildren we are looking at a
94 population collapse over the next
century and when I brought this up with
the other partners at my firm and I was
like Hey like it just doesn't seem like
there is any feasible economic future
for this country they're like yeah but
we pretend like that's not the case in
our investments like everybody knows
this but like if we accepted it then the
economy stops working Society stopped
working so we're just gonna ignore it
basically and when I came back to the
U.S it was like going back in time 20
years like I was in some sort of a
sci-fi movie and getting to be this one
person who saw where the future was
going to go and and having to be that
crazy person on the streets like no no
no you guys don't understand there's
countries further ahead than us on this
spectrum right now okay and we know a
few things we know there is no floor no
country has hit a fertility collapsed
floor yet we know that there is no level
of advanced fertility collapse where
people freak out or at least not until
it's too late because you look at Korea
right now and 60 of of Korean citizens
are over the age of 40. so it's it's
likely already too late for them to turn
this this problem around so we need to
turn this around before we hit that
level but the truth is we probably won't
and and we've got to think of solutions
for when we don't turn this around but
that's a different topic for later in
the interview well one of the most
common questions I imagine that people
ask is why should anyone care about how
many children another person has this is
my choice you can't impose me to have
kids if I don't want to have them why
should two guys sat on the internet be
telling the world about the dangers of
not having children people can go and do
other things with their lives now women
are allowed to be in the workplace men
can go their own way and play video
games and be a sigma male as much as
they want why should anyone care about
how many children another person has
so I I think that that's a really good
point and our
one of the things that people
look wrong about us
they're trying to increase reach the
world's population or that we are trying
to proselytize broadly to increase
fertility rates and and neither one of
those things is true if we are on the
Titanic right now no matter what the
Titanic hits the iceberg we are trying
to one make people aware that the
Titanic's about to hit an iceberg get
them in Lines by the rafts the ones who
want to survive start getting the rafts
in the water in a calm and orderly
fashion before people start panicking
because that's what's going to happen
and so what we promote is is trying to
get I mean I know my family is going to
be okay you know I I know that my
cultural group is going to be okay
broadly speaking
um so one I know that my family you know
I have eight kids and they have eight
kids and you do that for 11 Generations
that's more descendants than exist in
the world today I often say so I don't
need to worry about people like me the
reason I'm so loud about this is because
I'm worried about the the massive
collapse in in in cultural and ethnic
diversity the world is about to see
um and it it will be astonishing for
people uh I think in the far future that
there were more than like three ethnic
groups and three cultural groups or
something like that if we don't solve
this and so what we're trying to do is
just make people aware of this because
so much of the propaganda that people
are consuming is telling them things are
fine have less kids you're a good person
if you have left kids and I know you've
talked about this before on the show and
it is it is astonishing and I think when
we look at this Urban monoculture that
is erasing all of the genuine diversity
in our society uh one of its core
messages is negative utilitarianism that
that that uh the the the core evil thing
in the world is human suffering and that
human happiness just doesn't really
matter or it is largely outweighed by
human suffering and therefore it's
better if humans don't exist
and that's the end goal for the urban
monoculture I think for a lot of people
what do you mean when you say Urban
monoculture well okay so this sort of
gets down into like uh my personal
politics to some extent but I think that
if you look at Society right now it's
largely becoming divided into two
factions and there has been a major
political shift around what conservative
and Progressive means
um the progressive is the party of this
Urban monoculture which is a single sort
of cultural group or virus that infects
other cultural institutions and erases
was whatever makes them unique and
aligns all of their goals so if I talk
with a progressive Muslim or a
progressive Jew or a progressive
Catholic
um or a progressive Unitarian
Universalist and I scratch beneath the
surface often their morals their views
on gender their views on what future
they want for the world are all very
very similar if I look at conservatives
from each of those factions their
worldviews are very different and what
the conservative party seems optimizing
around so where the liberal party is
optimized around the goals of this
monoculture so spreading the monoculture
and reducing in the moment human
suffering that's why they promote things
like Haze you know like don't tell
somebody that it's unhealthy to be fat
because that can hurt their feelings in
the moment even though it like obviously
it's bad for them in the long term but
um the conservative movements all have
in a very distinct uh cultural histories
which they are trying to preserve and
that is often uh if I look at the
conservative movement today it's an
alliance of these older traditions and
newer but deviant and distinct
Traditions
um that are trying to maintain cultural
Fidelity and exist a hundred two hundred
years from now um and so when I talk
about the monoculture that's what I'm
talking about this thing that wants to
when my kids go to school say this is
what correct morality is this is the way
you should see the world and if your
parents are telling you anything else
they're deplorable and wrong is that not
the case with some factions from a
conservative side as well though yeah
yeah I know and I I call them sleeper
progressives they just want to erase all
other cultures the moment they gave
power but I think that right now I can
form an alliance with them because our
goals are aligned I think one of the
really cool things that we've seen with
the conservative party is you saw
something like when Andrew Tate
converted to Islam you know in the past
a conservative icon converting to Islam
a lot of people would have been wringing
their hands about that but a lot of
people were like you go you know at
least you found some Faith at least you
found some
tradition and so I think what we're
seeing there is more of a realization
that the the big bad these days is this
culture that's trying to homogenize the
world
interesting what would you say to the
well-meaning people from the Progressive
Movement that say it feels a little bit
bad to be tarnished with the brush as a
super virus I think that I'm you know
I'm just somebody that holds liberal
values I don't believe that I'm part of
some destructive force within the world
and and I think that there are people
who genuinely
um uh like within any movement you know
when when the Catholic Church used to be
the the iteration of this in European
society and they were trying to convert
everyone to their ways and the
Protestant Church during their own time
had periods like that in some countries
um the vast majority of Protestants
they're Catholics in those countries
were just decent well-meaning people
trying to live their lives but the ones
who controlled the cultural institutions
and were you know burning people at the
stake and and trying to ensure that
everybody fit this very narrow
definition of morality set by their
culture to me they were the the evil
ones within those institutions and today
when I talk about this this monoculture
um I think that the vast majority of
people who are members of it are just
like like the vast majority of of of of
Catholics and Protestants during periods
when when those cultural groups were
dominant in specific regions why is this
culture so effective
very interesting okay so it's evolved a
lot of new tactics that have never been
tried before so in our book The
pragmatist guide to crafting religion
what we essentially do is we argue that
Humanity could be thought of as sort of
an evolving firmware which is like our
biology our genes but on top of that
firm where there's evolving sets of
software and this software today we
often talk about memes as like things
that infect somebody and then cause them
to just turn around and infect other
people but historically most romantic
clusters actually augmented a person's
uh sort of biological Fitness the number
of surviving Offspring they had and
that's how they survived that's how I
mean if you look at things with a
secular mindset why things like Islam
and Judaism figured out stuff like hand
washing literally centuries before
science figured out hand washing
um and you see this across these
traditions for example if you look at
all of the old traditions almost all of
them have some arbitrary self denial
holiday like lent or Ramadan or Feast of
the firstborn or whatever right and and
just now after throwing out all of those
rich tools over the past you know 50 100
years secular society is like oh now we
gotta have our juice cleanses now we
gotta have our you know they're
realizing oh fasting and stuff like that
right it has positive mental effects
um and so I think that that if you see
these as different like evolving
cultural groups this super virus evolved
some very unique tactics and it is not
the same thing as a historic Progressive
Movement what it is is something so the
reason I call it a super virus that is
very much so when you talk about a super
bacteria or a superbug they typically
come up in things like hospitals where
you have a ton of people with a weakened
immune system all in a similar
environment with lots of sort of viruses
or bacteria that can that can
intermingle alongside antibiotics and
stuff like that this is what was created
by the internet this is why all of this
stuff started when social media happened
essentially you had a super spreader
environment where uh new memetic ideas
were able to test themselves against all
of the world's Traditions at the same
time optimize and react very quickly and
become incredibly virulent while uh
evolving strategies that had never been
tried before so one of the most
effective strategies that it uses is if
you look historically when if you look
at cultural groups as sort of like nodal
clouds that sort of overlap with each
other
um when you had a corrupted node within
a nodal cloud or a node that looked like
it was flipping what you would do if you
were a majority Protestant country or
majority Catholic country like a
Catholic came in and started preaching
or a Protestant came in and started
preaching you you'd burn them you'd burn
them at the stake often right
um or if somebody just had like random
cultural mutation in the same way you
have like random genetic mutation and
they believe something weird like they
were a witch and you burn them right
that's how you mean contained this level
of cultural Fidelity what the virus does
which is very interesting is it uh
organically determines
um when a node looks like it might be
flipping and then it essentially Shadow
bans the node it begins to deconnect
that node's links to all of the rest of
the Network's power structures and this
is really powerful because what it means
is the other nodes that might be allied
with that node they don't react the way
they would have historically when
somebody was being like burned at the
stake or something like that which is
actually why cancellation is a fairly
ineffective tactic and genuinely not
used that much when contrasted with just
this Shadow bending process of the
person just doesn't get a promotion if
it looks like they might be immune to
these ideas they just don't you know
their their papers get published a
little less you know uh certain
platforms begin to favor them less
within the algorithm
um and that's how it has been able to
maintain such control I think of the
upper echelons of our society
but it's not like every organization is
run by a progressive movement right
there are organizations out there that
seem to be a lot more open to new ideas
we're seeing pushback from a variety of
places to the opportunity for people to
have independent uh jobs so I would say
that it's not every organization so it
specifically targets the organizations
it can best use to maintain its
population levels
um and so those are typically
organizations that are involved in
education so you're looking at the
middle school system the high school
system and the college system or the
organization that it is most critical
that it maintains that actually
Stranglehold over and this again comes
to fertility issues of the populations
of the world if there is one population
that has a very low birth rate it is
this population uh this this Urban
monoculture
um and uh because of that the only way
it can repopulate its ideological
faction is through siphoning children
from other often more conservative
cultural traditions are in other ways
deviant cultural Traditions that are for
whatever reason having a lot of kids
okay getting back to fertility what
groups are doing particularly well and
particularly badly when it comes to
fertility this is a fascinating question
all right so um the the uh uh if you
look in a post-prosperity environment so
a lot of people they're like oh well
countries in Africa are doing really
well uh they have high fertility rates
or Muslim populations have high
fertility rates and it's like well
that's irrelevant of those populations
are in a country where the average
salary is under five thousand dollars a
year because that is where you get above
replacement fertility in pretty much
every country that's under five thousand
a year you get above replacement every
country above 5000 a year you typically
get below replacement fertility
um uh and so it's a level of desperate
poverty first of all that is often
misconstrued so you look at Latin
America Central America and South
America the Caribbean collectively as of
2019 so old news they follow every
population rate
um so it's really just a few of these
these poorest countries so I really
ignore any country at a high fertility
um if it's a poor country or if it's not
a wealthy country right and so I think
where you can see is some
misunderstandings that people have from
that so you look at populations like
Muslim populations when they enter
wealthier countries their populations
really crash or when the countries were
there the dominant social group so you
can look at Iran Iran's fertility rate
fell above below replacement a long time
ago and for uh since 2014 they've been
trying pretty much everything in their
power to try to get fertility rates back
above repopulation rate and their
government has a lot of control over the
populace and they are not able to
they're still only at 1.7
um so the groups that really show
resistance to this are Conservative
Christian groups and conservative Jewish
groups and this is why I always think
it's funny when people are like oh
you're talking about fertility rates you
must be about saving white people and
it's like
white conservative people are like the
only people on Earth who don't seem to
be disappearing in in the face of uh
prosperity-induced fertility collapse
the groups that are most at risk are the
Eastern Traditions even conservative
iterations of those Traditions are very
bad at resisting prosperity-induced
fertility collapse
prosperity-induced fertility collapse
what is the relationship between
prosperity and fertility well as I said
typically when it comes when a country
earns over 5000 USD a year uh fertility
begins to fall below replacement rate
yes
oh well so this is we can say nobody
quite knows but there is some evidence
as to what might be causing this what is
probably causing it is the ability to
engage with a modern economy
um so when somebody is not engaged with
the modern economy
um and not valuable to the modern
economy then uh the modern economy
basically ignores them and they go on
living the way humans have always lived
in having a lot of kids this is why
within developed countries so if you
look at a country like the US right uh
typically the less money you make the
more kids you have except when you're at
the very high end of the income Spectrum
so uh if you're making an average of
half a million dollars a year or more as
a family you will be an above
replacement fertility and in many ways
families at that income level are just
not like the economy isn't grabbing them
as much because they don't need the
economy as much so what's really
happening is if you look at our sort of
free market structure what it does is it
organically determines how to reward
anyone who has the probability of that
it believes has the probability of being
productive with just enough money to get
them to spend their time being
productive versus doing anything else
that might have long-term benefits to
the society like having kids or whatever
right I mean it's very very good at
doing this and then it draws them into
environments like cities where it
becomes even harder to have kids and
where they can um
anyway yeah where they can be more
productive and spend more time working
and generating money for this larger
economic system I was gonna say
it doesn't seem like it doesn't seem
realistic that this could be a large
behemoth
evely behind the scenes working to try
and get fertility rates down it seems
more likely that it is a natural
byproduct of a capitalist machine that
wants to have workers who are available
as much as possible who don't take
maternity opportunity leave who are
buying their clothes and taking their
holidays consuming and producing and
pumping money back into the system
everything you're saying there and
that's also what I mean when I talk
about the virus I don't think any
decision is made maliciously I think
everybody thinks they're a good guy
everyone's trying to do what they think
is best for the world but sometimes
um sort of a cultural evolutionary
pressures can create incentive systems
that lead to actions that in the long
term will have consequences that I think
most people would think are bad okay at
the beginning you mentioned a bunch of
other uh contributing factors Prosperity
being one of them what would the what
were the other elements gender equality
and education are typically the other
two run us through those
well um gender equality when when uh it
is often specifically female education
um when women begin to have a choice as
to what they do and can participate in
the economy
um
I I don't think that it's that they're
choosing not to have kids I think that
that is a misunderstanding of what we're
seeing in the data I think it's that
they prioritize economic stability and
basically having their life in order
before they decide to start having kids
but the way our economic system is
structured people often don't really
feel they have their life in order till
their mid-30s or 40s or and and at that
time they can no longer have kids
um and so I think that that is why it is
not that women are choosing jobs over
kids it's that they're choosing jobs
then kids and their biological clocks
run out while at the same time
um and I think this is something that's
really undersold when people talk about
fertility collapse is the absolute
collapse of marriage markets in our
society
um it is uh I saw a tweet and I couldn't
agree with it more being in a happy
marriage these days uh feels a bit like
catching the last Chopper at an arm
um because uh it is hard it is hard out
there to find a good partner and we have
seen a collapse of the systems that
previously insured people found a great
long-term uh dedicated Partners well
that's the point it's not just about
declining birth rights it's also about
declining dating so yeah 50 of guys aged
18 to 30 say that they are not looking
for casual or long-term relationships
I mean you know that that's an
unbelievably shocking statistic to say
that your natural biological inclination
as a guy During the period of your life
when you're going to have the highest
testosterone that you're going to have
is just checking out completely of
either casual or long-term relationships
the same thing goes for women broadly as
well that it's just not good so how do
you fold in this decline in dating as
well as children
I mean how do you fold it in uh it's
it's what I just say this a problem and
one of the things we look at I mean
we've written multiple books on like the
progress guided relationships the
fragment is guide of sexuality looking
at this problem trying to come up with
solutions to this problem
um and I think that this brings us to
what the real solution to this problem
is in a broader context not just dating
um not just uh but but also fertility
claps also the cultural so whenever
anybody first hears about fertility
collapse they often want to use it as a
way to justify I think the talking
points they wanted to push before it
became a problem in there on on their
table like as soon as they accept it's a
problem then they're like oh I can use
this to push things I wanted to push
already so they'll say things like oh
well you should do cash handouts except
we know that doesn't really work you
know hungry spend five percent of its
GDP last year doing it and they got the
fertility rate up by like 1.6 when when
it's dropping like three percent year
over year in a lot of places in the
world that's really irrelevant like
China 2020 dropped 20 2021 drop 13 in
2022 covet lockdowns are over it should
be going up only went up 0.18 you know
so uh you're just seeing a 1.6 increase
for five percent of your GDP is
irrelevant
um so uh I know and people are often
like well you could spend more what if
you spend 50 of your GDP on this but if
it's naturally dropping every year then
you can never catch that toad if you're
doing it by by spending money and it's
the same with things like free child
care God I would like free child care
you know I plan to have seven kids or
something like that uh but in the
countries that offer it it does seem to
help fertility a little bit like maybe
like three or four percent which is a
pretty good amount but it's not enough
to offset the trends that we see
um and then you talk to conservative
groups and they're like well what we
should do is uh I'm talking far
conservative groups not not ones like me
but but they're like we should create
ethnic States basically um you know stop
immigration uh have one culture one
country except if you actually look at
the statistics the countries in
prosperous countries with the lowest
fertility rates are often ethnic States
you know like South Korea stuff like
that you look at the countries that have
been most resistant to fertility
collapse in the prosperous world you're
looking at countries like Israel in the
US some of the most diverse countries
and you can even see this with cultural
groups across countries so you look at
like Iran remember I mentioned Iran
famously has a real big fertility
country and they're basically a Shia
monoculture but you look at Shia Muslims
in India at similar economic levels
where it's much more diverse and their
fertility rates like twice what it is in
Iran
um so uh I I think that that's the first
thing so then the second question
becomes well how do you actually solve
this problem right if you look around
the world
uh and we've already talked about it I
mean the solution's sort of staring Us
in the face the groups that are
resistant to this are the ones that
deviate in some way from the urban
monoculture most of them are
traditionalist religious groups
um and there are some traditionalist
religious groups that are more resistant
to this fertility collapse than others
and some that seemed like they were
resistant and then all of a sudden
collapsed uh Mormons are an example of
this like Mormons had great fertility
rates than like five or six years ago
something happened and now they're
probably below replacement rate
um and so uh what that tells me is that
the solution to this is going to come at
the level of cultural experimentation
both fortifying our traditional cultures
to be more resistant to the new threats
they're facing but also potentially
inventing new cultures that work uh with
with technology uh the internet new
strategies that are open to us which is
what my family's trying to do
tell me more about that
okay um
yeah all right so I can go deeper into
this so we have everything from like our
own traditions of the family our own
sort of the moral framework different
ways of naming our kids different ways
of dressing to an extent like we look
weird to other people and a lot of
people are like you guys look like
freaks don't you know your kids will be
weird don't you know they'll be bullied
and I go you know look around the world
which families which cultures are going
to exist in the future it's it's ones
like the Amish the Hasidic you know
wherever you look they look different
they dress different they name their
kids different things it's because the
when you call something cringe when you
call something different or weird or
freaky what you are saying is it
differentiates from the cultural norms
to which you are accustomed those
cultural norms became the dominant
cultural norms because they had a good
immune system because they were good at
dehumanizing the other and calling
people freaky and stuff like that but
the reality is that if you want to join
this game and this is why I'm out here
this is why I'm feeling I don't want I a
future where it's just my kids it's a
failure right where it's just my family
I want as much diversity into the future
as possible that's why I'm shouting this
I want people to join us I want them to
experiment and fortify themselves and
not become overly complacent uh with
their existing Traditions if their kids
are being effectively peeled out by this
monoculture
um it's very interesting to me you know
I sometimes you hear people in the rain
they go why don't you just convert to
like a traditional religious framework
and it's because most of those
Frameworks are right now on the
downtrend in terms of their ability to
continue a high fertility and maintain
their kids I do want them to find new
systems to protect themselves against
that but that's that's why that's just
just going to Traditions isn't the
answer anymore uh the the the the virus
or whatever you want to call it has
gotten too good at finding kids
um and so we have to find new systems
and also the the just the the
environment the kids are in with
internet with social media uh it's so
different and then with AI that they're
going to face how do you keep your kid
from dating an AI girlfriend when they
can have a deep fake that's perfect and
hot and loves them right uh you you they
need to want something other than
Hedonism and that's a difficult message
to convey to kids if they adopt the
dominant social mores today so to recap
what you were talking about to do with
this uh
sort of almost monotheistic uh future or
this this sort of monoculture future
that we would end up with if birth rate
decline continues
for the people that might look at this
and say well this is you trying to put
forth you want it to be a white ethno
State you want it to be more of your
progeny that are out there your point is
that that is the subgroup which is one
of the few which are continuing to be
okay at the moment we're actually going
to lose genetic and racial diversity if
we allow the current trends to continue
because some of the groups that are
reproducing with the lowest fertility
rates are the ones that add to that
diversity so in the future what you end
up with is a very small number of
different cohorts of stuff like Amish
stuff like not even Mormons apparently
anymore who are then Downstream going to
be the ones that fill out the entire
country yeah if we do nothing uh the
future is really just uh conservative
Christians and conservative Jews and
maybe conservative Muslims
um those seem to be the only groups that
are just like persistently resistant to
this so that's a pretty sort of uh Bland
future racially from yeah and there's
some groups that in the very near future
like if I if I was looking at this like
an ecologist right like the groups I
would be probably most concerned about
right now are groups like the James and
the Percy who I think like a lot of
Americans don't think about but they're
some of the oldest most distinct
cultures in the world right now and they
will almost certainly have collapsed in
in population by the end of the century
to the point where it'll be difficult
for them to carry on their Traditions
um coming back to that conversation
about we get prosperous we give women
education they enter the job market and
they have other things to do with their
life
what's your proposal presumably you're
not saying that we need to rip women out
of the workplace or education and if it
is the case that we don't want people to
be less prosperous and we also want to
let people choose what they want to do
if this is what they want to do if women
don't want to to to have kids or if they
don't feel like they're ready and they
don't want to have kids until they are
they're concerned about the living cost
and the cost to bring your child into
this ordering concerned about the
environment they're concerned about
losing their life freedom and struggling
to find the right partner whatever it is
they've got better things to do with all
of the money that they've just found
like why why shouldn't they be allowed
to do that so I would say I think they
should be allowed to do that and I think
that real feminists today when I say a
feminist I mean somebody who wants
gender well I don't know if feminism is
the right word people who want gender
equality whatever word you want to use
for wanting gender equality in 100 years
in 200 years to be an option
right uh you're sort of at the Crux of
History right now because no group that
really has it gender equality except for
maybe Israel we can get to that later
there's questions there whatever but um
uh is anywhere close to above
repopulation rate so those groups and
those cultural Traditions are going to
eventually disappear
um and and what they will do is they
will get better in the short term at
taking the kids of people from these
conservative Traditions but eventually I
mean just just the way cultural
Evolution works the conservative
Traditions will build systems that have
resistance to whatever technique that
they're using
um and and they will not be able to
repopulate that way anymore
um so uh if you actually care about this
then you can join the grand experiment
and the grand experiment is and this is
something we genuinely don't know yet is
it possible to have gender equality and
a high fertility rate my family so like
when I look at what my wife and I did um
I was asked to be on this podcast the
only thing here not in my choice I would
have her on typically with me you know
we write our books together we run our
companies together is one solution to
the gender equality question which is to
do everything together write your books
together run your companies together
raise your kids together right uh but
there are other solutions to this
question that people can experiment with
and what I love is this isn't a question
of what's the most moral way to do
things uh sort of the future will decide
who was actually successful who was able
to have a lot of kids motivate the
continuation of the tradition through
their children you know you get 18 years
to pitch to your kids that your way of
living is a good way of living and if
your kids don't like that or they don't
agree with that I I think we're we're
blessed and that we live in a society
where they can choose something else
um and so uh you know I I think that we
are going to have a hopefully a lot of
people trying new ways of living new
ways of trying to achieve gender
equality like my family you know doing
everything with your spouse isn't the
way that gender equality is typically
envisioned when people talk about it but
it is a form of gender equality can
liberalism last under demographic
decline what about no no it's gone it's
dead I mean if you talk conservative
liberalism maybe like if you're talking
about like traditional liberalism if
you're talking about the Progressive
Movement I often say it's a bit like uh
if you get a certain blast of radiation
right your your DNA can be scrambled
your cells can no longer replicate you
don't know that you're a dead man
walking yet you know before you begin to
feel the pain but there is nothing that
can be done to save you at that point uh
the fertility rate is so low is in that
Community there's really nothing that
can be done even if you look at the
genetic level right now it's so funny
you know conservatives are often like
hey you're on our team why are you
alerting them to the scope of the
problem you know we win if we just sit
back and let them disappear and it's
like they're going to disappear no
matter what uh if you look at the
heritability of voting patterns which is
around 30 to 50
um you know whether this is done with
identical twin studies and stuff this is
not like fringe science you can look up
genopolitics on Wikipedia it's like
mainstream uh uh and you look at current
fertility rates in a countries like the
us we should expect about a one standard
deviation shift conservative in voting
patterns over the next Century uh in the
next 10 or 20 years we'll see a massive
shift to the left because they've
success as family units get atomized
um uh people vote more progressively
when people don't have kids they vote
more progressively
um but after that you're going to see a
massive shift in the other direction and
it's just inevitable from the statistics
at this point has any country tried to
fix this problem through
authoritarianism and how does that work
a lot have it just doesn't
uh order 77 707 or something I don't
know maybe I'm getting confused with
Star Wars orders but they uh decided
under the Communist period that they
were gonna ban abortion
and they thought oh this will be great
um it'll it'll shoot up fertility rates
and it did for a very brief period of
time like two years or something like
that then people found ways around it
and then after the law was repealed um
fertility rates crashed because
fertility or having kids became
associated with
um uh really uh poverty often or low
social status
um and so uh you can look at countries
like Iran that have been trying to
implement things it's really funny I
watched what China is implementing right
now and it's like Iran tried all of this
10 years ago you guys you can just look
at what happened you're gonna have to
get really aggressive if you actually
want to solve this and that's where I
get really scared because a lot of
countries what we have found is that you
can dictatorially like people have tried
to you know ban abortions be like what's
happening in China now likely shutting
down access to um
uh uh uh vasectomy clinics and stuff
like that
um
so countries can ban these things
um and and then it doesn't work because
it doesn't work so then what did they do
then you get real handmaid's tale and
that gets scary for me it was actually
the piece on us and the guardian and
they were like they had quoted me saying
something like that and they go well
that sounds like a threat and I'm like
are you like do you have the mind of a
child like it's like when I tell a child
don't touch the stove you're gonna burn
your hands they're like that sounds like
a threat I'm trying to protect you here
uh but there's nothing I can do you know
at the end of the day the Titanic's
hitting the iceberg I'm just trying to
to to to prepare for what's gonna happen
next but what happened next get really
interesting
sorry to keep talking I don't want to no
keep going okay so what's really cool
here is if you look historically so when
I started hearing about this I was in
Korea right you know 95 population
collapsed it was funny to think about
because the memory is so strong there of
you know less than a century ago Japan
coming over you know murdering in in in
in Korea and China millions of people
and there's this conflict there China
Korea Japan you know trying to well less
Korea trying to take over the other two
but mostly the other two trying to take
over each other you know there's there's
a lot of uh history there and it's so
funny that now uh any one of them could
just I'm like how does Korea solve this
I guess they could import people from
Japan or China no you can't because
their populations are collapsing any one
of them could non-violently just like
walk into their neighbor a hundred years
from now they were able to motivate
their citizens to kill people but they
were not able to motivate them to have
kids and this is what's so interesting
it changes the game but in a really
beautiful way you look at people like
Putin who don't get the new world yet
right the world used to be you keep out
immigrants you maintain cultural
integrity and when you want to spread
your culture you go to other countries
you kill other people you subjugate them
and you force them to convert to your
culture but that's not the game anymore
so you look at Russia which has a
desperately low fertility rate attacking
their coastless cultural and like ethnic
neighbors uh uh the Ukraine who also
have the desperately low fertility rate
both killing like an entire generation
here
um and they're never going to recover
from this it it is it is not the game
anymore the game that they're still
playing you win now not through War but
with love and I say love and not just
sex or spamming kids because if you spam
kids they're gonna breed like caged
panda bears like everyone else they're
going to not have any dedication to
whatever weird thing about your culture
caused you to have a lot of kids
and they're just going to drift off into
this monoculture and disappear so what
you need to do is you need to have a lot
of kids but you also need to do a great
job raising them make them proud of your
cultural group make them want to
continue that cultural group and those
are the people who are going to be
around in the future and I'm really
excited about that because that is so
much better than the old system of
murdering people
foreign
explain or illustrate what a world
in deep population decline would be like
yeah so the first thing and I often
don't talk about you know I don't the
first thing is all economies are going
to collapse pretty much the Western so
our economic system is sort of a pyramid
scheme a lot of people know this but
let's just spill it out
um if you uh look historically people go
as this truism if I put money on the
stock market that money grows on average
that has been happening because of two
things the number of workers has been
growing exponentially and the
productivity per worker has been growing
around linearly a little exponentially
but mostly linearly yes technology has
been growing exponentially but the
productivity per worker is about linear
um or at least not close to the
explosion worker population that is why
the economy has always been growing if
the worker population in the developed
world begins to collapse exponentially
and people are like well why don't
people in the in in in in desperately
poor countries count because by
definition they have small economies
that's why they're poor because their
economies are small so you don't need to
wait for the world's population to begin
to collapse for all of the developed
world economies to begin to collapse so
you're going to begin to see the economy
shrink on average it won't be like it is
now where on average things go up on
average things go down when things go
down on average people react very
differently you don't leave your money
in the stock market anymore you're going
to have math withdrawals of money from
the stock market and then this begins to
break a bunch of other systems so you
see things like Detroit okay so why did
Detroit ultimately end up having the
problems it was having and there's a few
reasons
one is our society use this miraculous
cheat code called debt now I'm a private
Equity VC guy I'm very familiar with
debts let's just talk a little bit about
how debt works and why it's such a
miracle if I'm making a 10 investment
and eight dollars is that in its debt
and two dollars is equity and that
investment grows to just twelve dollars
My Equity in that investment has doubled
but if it shrinks just one dollar My
Equity has halved we leveraged our land
our businesses leverage means took out
debt against our cities our states our
Nations it's not people look at like the
national debt no no no no it's leverage
to the hilt all the way down if things
start shrinking the whole thing falls
apart and yes national debt is a little
different than personal debt and stuff
like that but what you are beginning to
go to see is essentially what we saw in
Detroit so people are like oh my house
will be worth lessons that's great yeah
it's great if houses go down 20 maybe 50
but when people know a house is always
going to decrease in price it decreases
to a dollar and when a house is a dollar
you know like what you saw in Detroit
right
um when a house is a dollar there's no
reason to maintain it because houses
costs a lot to maintain as anyone who is
a homeowner knows you've put so much
money into your house but you justify it
because okay well it's an asset that I
own and people stop investing in assets
that way so the whole way we relate to
money and the economy is going to change
so endless Urban blight economy is not
functioning the way that they're
supposed to function so then what
happens
well where do people begin to invest
well one is what what happens in a
negative scenario so negative scenario
and this is what I'm terrified of is the
developed World finds a cheat code which
is immigrants
um what they realize is that they can
cheese their collapsing populations
through Mass immigration but this cheat
code only works if they keep really the
only country the only collection of
countries that has an above repopulation
rate right now which is mostly in Africa
desperately poor so now you have an
economic incentive a gun to the head of
the entire developed world that Africa
must stay in Desperate poverty so you
use you use Africa almost like a
breeding ground to create the future
population to be pulled across into
other countries yeah it's it's sick but
that seems to be like when I talk to
them that's like actually the going plan
right now uh but I don't think it's
gonna work I don't think that that plan
is going to work so we can ignore it so
what really happens well so that because
their economies are going to collapse
before they can do that sort of mass
what right now you're getting a lot of
immigrants but it's immigrants who want
to leave and I think what a lot of
people forget is a lot of people don't
want to leave even when Ireland was
suffering the Potato Famine what a lot
of people don't know is that the
landlords there was a rash of landlord
murders at the time
um and uh so they got scared and so they
would uh sometimes I don't know how
frequently offered to pay for all of
their tenants to go to America on coffin
ships it was horrible but at least it
was the idea that's that's the way I
think many people would be imported
these days right so a horrible
immigration but at least you know they
had the option to leave during the
Potato fam and during this time when
people would walk into town they thought
everyone was dead and then the corpses
would start animating and they realized
that they were just stuck like it was
bad but but the majority a lot of people
wanted to stay and so I think what
they're going to realize is that this
this trickle of immigrants that we have
right now is pretty close to the max
trickle of immigrants you can get and
it's only just offsetting population
collapse right now and when they get to
the US when they get to Europe their
fertility rate collapse first generation
immigrants in the US only have a
fertility rate of 1.7 well below
repopulation rate so it's not like you
could just bring immigrants and they
solve the problem you need to keep
importing people but anyway okay
ignore all this okay so world's
collecting where do you put your money
if on average the economy is collapsing
this is where it gets cool because we
get something we haven't had in a long
time individual human lives start to
matter individual human cultures start
to matter if you have a cultural group
that has a high fertility rate and it's
technophilic like they engage with
technology
um and even if they're technophobic but
less of their technophobic that becomes
the group you want to invest in that
becomes a place you want to place money
because that's the only place that you
can be fairly sure is going to grow in
aggregate in the future
and that creates a totally different
world economy than the one we have now
and it's a very interesting World
economy and so when people say like what
actually is our foundation sort of doing
really what we're doing is we're trying
to identify those groups right now and
build connections between them so that
we can have a pluralistic group of
thriving economies of the willing and of
the Willing what I mean is the people
who were willing to have kids willing to
give those kids a good enough life that
they wanted to stay in that culture
since learning about the current trends
of population collapse declining birth
rates Etc I've started to view a lot of
the problems that we're facing
especially the cultural ways that people
see dating Family Life having kids
relationships with their parents uh the
future of the the world through a very
different lens and um there's a trend at
the moment that's only recently like
within the last couple of months I've
started seeing come out on the internet
which is one of men in their 20s getting
vasectomies as a protest against
feminists that want to be able to have
free and easy sex it's literally like a
clap back where you've got the pill I'm
gonna get the snip have you seen this I
I I'm a fan I mean I I focus more on the
transmaxing movement have you heard of
that no what's transmaxing oh it's
fascinating so it's a group of guys
um who are not like traditional Transit
that they don't have gender dysphoria
they don't feel like they were born the
wrong gender they're just like as a guy
and as a not particularly attractive or
not particularly wealthy guy I got dealt
a bad hand
hormone therapy is easy to get access to
these days I'm going to become a woman
um and uh that's what it is it is with
what goal what's the goal of it the goal
is to get an easier life I mean if
you've been consuming a fire hose of red
pill and mgtow content you know it can
sound like a pretty good idea to a lot
of people I think oh because women have
got it so much easier than men do
therefore if I become the closest thing
that I can to a woman it's going to fix
all of my problems okay fair enough I
mean yeah that that is an approach and
the
optional elected vasectomy in your 20s
thing I think sort of sit on the Shelf
next to each other for I wouldn't have
predicted this on my 2023 bingo card
um but yeah so just everything that I
see you know this
stophavingkids.org who you may be
familiar with like this really serious
anti-natalist movement they they have
the involuntary anti-natalist movement
they wanted they want to sterilize the
entire population they're like
terrorists there's this they're scary
people wow and what's the justification
for this I'm gonna guess climate
oh no uh so they're really just negative
utilitarians I think most anti-natalism
and um for people who aren't familiar
with negative utilitarianism it's the
belief that negative emotions are bad
but positive emotions aren't inherently
good or that a human life a a negative
emotions are more acute than positive
emotions or they're just much higher in
volume the best uh the best the best
example of this that I learned from a
friend was imagine that you got to spend
the rest of your life in the optimal
amount of bliss maxing out your pleasure
compare this to an existence where for
the remainder of your life you were
spent in maximum torture with as much
pain as you can imagine
or let's say that you did one and then
did the other would one be worth the
other and most people have an
inclination that suffering is somehow
worse than pain that you are and and
then you net out after a human life the
what was the what was the group that
involuntary and teenagers yeah
um they basically say that a human life
is net suffering overall therefore it is
morally reprehensible to bring any
future life into this world because the
net experience is one of pain and
torment and displeasure yeah and I I
actually suspect that when we see this
Urban monoculture I've described begin
to really dwindle in size and the only
people who are left are the most
extremist was in it we're going to begin
to have to deal with terrorists on that
front and that really scares me but
here's the thing who's to know we aren't
already dealing with terrorists on that
front look at declining fertility rates
around the world today biological
fertility declining sperm counts de
reclining testosterone who's to say
there isn't something in the water you
know what I mean I know that you think
that someone's purposely doing this I I
don't know man I would I would Hazard
towards hanlon's razor with stuff like
that like you know the the incentives
align for people to believe that they're
doing something which is
sympathetic empathetic caring whether it
be because of the environment whether it
be you know I mean that the the
environmental thing is is such an
interesting argument to me because if
you think that a planet that has too
many people on it is bad for the planet
wait until you see what a planet that
has too few people on it is like it is
oh well you know we existed uh 200 years
ago there was only half a billion people
or a billion people or whatever on the
planet the planet's been fine with this
many people on before it's like yeah but
what's the experience of the life like
for the people that are on it what about
all of the animals that you want to save
what about all of the interjections that
you want to make with regards to
controlling the climate to ensuring that
all of the different ecosystems that you
care about continue so I've had a lot of
pushback about talking about declining
birth rates and you know I'm whatever
you want to say like dating sphere
adjacent sometimes although I'm speaking
to the researchers I'm not you know
doing a panel show with a bunch of
different people screaming at them
saying that they're going to become
Loveless harpies in their 30s
um and I know I feel like the the
criticisms that people have about
anybody that brings up declining birth
rates either haven't thought about the
problem sufficiently well or have a
really really [__] perverse and
malicious incentive because
anybody that sees a discussion about
declining birth rates is anything other
than a concern for the future of human
lives that haven't yet existed they're
just not philosophically sophisticated
yeah I'm totally open I'm totally open
to to having the discussion that maybe
um there is an optimal amount of
population that would be great to have
on the earth I think the carrying
capacity of the planet is significantly
higher than where we're at at the moment
I agree and I think that climate Mastery
and all the rest of it we have a ton of
work to do for a whole host of things
whether that be AI alignment whether
that be gray goo from nanotechnology but
like pick your existential risk of
choice right
but like [__] off bro if you think that
I'm not going to talk about the exit the
most existential of existential risks
individually to you and here's the other
thing so folding this in a lot of people
will have listened to the Stephen Shore
episode that I did which was absolutely
fantastic I really love him as a
demographer and a researcher in this
world and
the the novel an interesting Insight the
really novel interesting Insight that
I'm going to kind of add into my world
view with regards to this that I've
learned from you today is looking at
what happens when you roll the clock
forward over a longer timeline with
which groups are going to continue to
survive and which cultures are going to
continue to survive if it's the case
that you say that you care about a
particular movement continuing to be uh
pushed Through the Ages because this is
something that we should care about
let's say it's reducing the amount of
people that are on the planet to
restrict climate change or let's just
say let's just say that it's climate
change overall right
if you have given the fact that uh
political leaning is 50 heritable if you
don't have any children who do you think
is going to continue that particular
philosophy that you've got like you are
literally making your ideology a Dying
Breed yes
no I I couldn't agree more and I think
one of the things that I always think
you know when you're talking about
biodiversity and stuff like this it I
always wonder like do these people like
not think into the future right now from
what we know about our planet humans are
the only species that can seed a new
biome we are the only species that can
get off planet right so if we see it a
new biome in a million and 10 million
years it'll be just as rich as our own
we could feed thousands hundreds of
thousands of new biomes if Humanity
doesn't win through this eye of the
needle we're about to go through if
Humanity does die off well I mean
everything we know about physics today
says the sun will eventually expand and
all life will go extinct it's end game
you know if you care about biodiversity
in the long run humans are critical to
maximizing that
um although I will modify one thing you
said I think that there is a logical
argument for negative utilitarianism I
think there's a logical argument for
getting rid of if humans I don't agree
with it these people are against my
cultural group but I don't think that
they're just like completely insane
either
do you think it's a moral obligation to
have children then with all of this sort
of folded together
I think different people have different
moral Frameworks they're optimizing for
I think if somebody believes that their
moral framework should continue to exist
into the future 200 300 years into the
future like gender equality or something
like that and you don't have kids you
have morally failed if you however are
just like no it doesn't matter if my
belief system dies out with me
um then yeah whatever you know I I I'm
not going to tell you that your morals
are wrong because I think that that
morality is one of those things where I
believe that my morals are right but uh
if I go around trying to police everyone
else's morality I'm just gonna have a
bad time so that's that Line in the Sand
is one I've been really interested in
playing about with I absolutely agree
that some sort of handmaid's tale future
where women uh kept in pens like cows so
that they can keep the future of the
population going is wrong also telling
women that the only way that you can
live a fulfilling life is by doing some
domestic version of that also is wrong
but I can't see why there isn't any
sympathy out there in the world for the
reverse of this situation what about all
of the people who were told you don't
need to have kids to have a fulfilling
life that did want to become mothers
that had their preferences nudged in the
opposite direction break through the
fertility window and then grieve for
families that they never had like where
is the finger pointing going in the
other direction because I I don't see
anybody
unironically saying that women need to
get out of the boardroom and get back in
the bedroom to start producing more
children like I think that they're just
saying look maybe you should think about
the current cultural norms that are
being pushed and and take them with a
big spoonful of salt yeah and I think
they're familiar with things that mean
my wife feel
is it uh parrot households with two
working parents the kids actually
perform better academically and have
better emotional health than parents who
stay at home it's a small effect but
what I'm saying is is that I think that
there's this intuition that only the
traditional way of doing things is
correct
um and that the truth is is what is
correct is whatever ends up working in
in the long term for human civilization
because nothing is really working right
now and so I just encourage people to if
they think I can't be a mom and in the
boardroom I I would encourage you to
rethink the way you're structuring your
family rethink the way you're
structuring finding a partner you know
earlier we were talking about dating
markets and one of the things that our
foundation is doing
because we're working to try to create
and promote new types of dating apps uh
maybe even recreate the London season
um you know something like that but the
travels between places like the Olympics
where you have you know a bunch of the
single people go but there's some rules
that make it harder to just uh have a
really low switching cost between
partners which is one of the big
problems that we're dealing with right
now
um so with a lot of this it's about
experimenting with new social
Technologies and understanding that
there probably are ways to have it all
much more than I think people want to
accept because it requires trying new
things and being called a freak by other
people what about people that say it's
too expensive to bring a child into this
world well why why are poorer people
having more kids if if it's an issue of
cost then uh you what you should see is
a line where people have more kids the
more money they have but typically the
line goes in the other direction within
and between countries until you get to
like ludicrous levels of wealth like
half a million dollars a year so
um what I say is it's enormously
expensive it is a massive lifestyle
sacrifice it absolutely is a lifestyle
sacrifice but is it too expensive I
think that's the real thing is it too
expensive is it that you can't afford it
or is it that you would need to like us
you know we had to leave a city we moved
to a rural area we changed the type of
jobs we could get because of that you
know we made a lot of sacrifices to do
this
um and I understand that for for
families unless socially economically
advantaged positions they have to make
even more sacrifices
um but uh you know when a family decides
they want a lot of kids they do it and I
think in addition to that this is
another area one of the projects that we
worked in was Project Eureka which was a
town for like single moms that had kids
and other people had kids and who wanted
to co-raise kids because there are
social Technologies we can try and I
would really like to see these commune
systems and stuff like that begin to pop
up more because I think as an investment
Prospect they were a really good
long-term investment Prospect if you
look at the model that I was talking
about earlier
the
challenges of other people the reason
that people say it's too expensive to
bring a child into this world I don't
think that they're talking about the
cost on their finances I think they're
talking about the cost on their freedom
oh and you know it's if you look at the
reasons that are given for a lot of
non-dators at the moment for people that
are checking out of the dating Market
it's just got better things to do not
wanting to lose personal freedom there's
this huge huge study that was done by
Pew and uh it just came back that people
were just distracted so what it seems is
that
if you are more financially enabled
there are more things that you can do
with your finances which means that you
can go abroad to Bali why not go to Bali
for two weeks or if you have the kid you
can't go to Bali for two weeks that the
girl with a list thing which you must
have seen that came off Tick Tock a girl
printed up 350 reasons not to have a
child and then printed them all on a
piece of paper and the reasons range
from stuff like child is literally a
parasite inside of you to can't wear my
cute high heels anymore can't do brunch
on Sundays
yeah so I want to get into this I'm
really excited so there are I think two
core reasons that people don't have kids
within the category that you're talking
about here it's because they're
optimizing for their personal happiness
now this can be broad satisfaction
contentment whatever word you want to
use but it's some sort of emotional
optimization or they're optimizing for
their own position within a local status
hierarchy this can be showing off to
people on Twitter or whatever you know
the trips that you're doing or the
things that you're doing with your life
because you think that these make you
you know like better or higher within
some some group if students you're not
optimizing for one of those two things
typically having kids or I suppose you
could say that I'm trying to make the
world a better place uh along some sort
of framework like donating to like
protecting ecology or something like
that like a lot of that leaps back to
status though yeah a lot of that Loops
back to status so I think what we're
gonna see and this is really cool
because it's Gonna Change what it means
to be human
when people I mean even more than the
other options people have right now when
Robo sexuality I always go back to the
future Futurama episode about this that
it predicted this when people can start
dating AIS and you can have your deep
fake girlfriend and stuff like that and
then eventually people will be able to
go into pods and live any virtual
reality lifestyle they want when these
sorts of things become possible and they
likely will was in my grandkids lifetime
at least if not our own
pretty much everyone who's optimizing
for status or personal pleasure is going
to be cold from the gene pool and any
cultural group that can't motivate
people to optimize for something else is
going to be removed from the system and
that is going to fundamentally change
what it means to be human and likely
have a pretty big impact on sort of the
human sociological profile in terms of
the genetic screening that's going to
cause it's going to nudge the genetic
disposition because the only cohorts
that are left are going to have a
particular type of predisposition
another time that's going to right yeah
that's really really interesting because
you know we all have this this balance
between hedonic pleasure and meaning
that we seek in the future you know it's
most parents I don't think if you were
to test them on a minute by minute basis
it's not the most pleasurable thing in
the world to raise a child looking at
some of the studies that I've seen it's
not it's not massively pleasurable but
it's incredibly meaningful and you know
there has to be some sort of a spectrum
where on one side someone lives for a
life that in retrospect they're glad
they lived and on the other side someone
lives a life that moment to moment
they're happy that they're living and
you know that spectrum between the two
Am I Living For a future that's meaning
or am I living for a now that's pleasure
yeah well I'm so excited well I love
what you're getting at here
which is how do you balance these two
and the really cool thing is that
biologically we're already optimized to
have kids and I think a lot of the
unhappiness that comes in society today
is that people forget that all of your
ancestors had kids they had sex and they
had kids or almost all of them did right
um and so humans are programmed to find
genuine contentment and happiness of a
deeper kind and a more meaningful kind
than they can get from almost anything
else
from continuing down the path that had
led to our species being successful so
far and I think when you look at a lot
of influencers right now if you look at
a lot of unhappiness they are showing
people what people are sort of
biologically optimized for right after
they go through puberty
without people realizing that that
optimization program changes as you get
older I often uh they're the joke that I
got in trouble for on on Twitter which
is to say that I don't know if you know
blippi he's like a Blues Clues sort of
character who dances around around fire
trucks for kids and is like yeah I'm
driving a fire truck I'm I'm playing in
a dump truck I'm I'm playing on a
playground you know and kids are like oh
this is the perfect life before they go
through puberty they see this that's
what they're optimized for they're
optimized for play and exploration as an
adult you see this and you're like oh my
God his life looks terrible
um I mean obviously he probably makes a
lot of money but I mean you wouldn't
actually want to live that way and I
often argue that that Andrew Tate is
sort of the blippi for teenagers
um this is what a teenage boy thinks is
the ideal adult life but to an actual
like grown man you see this and you can
see sort of the the deadness and he's
like yeah I have to like please multiple
women a day or they'll leave me and then
I won't be able to maintain sort of the
thing that I built up and I'm like oh my
God I can't even imagine like having to
just like have a routine of constantly
having sex every day so that I can at a
base level maintain my economic Empire
um and but to a young boy that sounds oh
that's the best because humans go
through a second puberty when they have
kids your testosterone drops
dramatically you begin to gain happiness
from different sources and it's a deeper
kind of happiness and with young women
it's the same thing with young women
they get told oh you're gonna love
traveling the world you're going to love
a certain point this stuff just becomes
draw you know
um
because you were biologically programmed
to one of them not everyone is you know
people's biological programming is a bit
different you know I could say that on
average human males are biologically
programmed to find human females
attractive but obviously not all human
males find human females of pressure so
a few people don't go through this shift
later in life but when you optimize
around the things that give you
happiness when you are a teenager in
your whole society tells you to optimize
around those things you hit middle age
and you're like why doesn't anything
really make me happy anymore why aren't
video games making me happy anymore why
aren't the the things I used to do why
does these status games not make me
happy anymore and it's because your
culture used to tell you hey you need to
move on to your next stage of life but
you don't have that culture anymore
because you're in this bubble
going back to what you said about status
yeah and how
status
provides a incentive for people to
behave in particular ways ways that
allow them to advertise their fancy trip
to Bali and brunch and whatever on a on
a Sunday on social media have you
considered a way of reprogramming status
full activities so that motherhood
becomes pedestalized again
I hate to say this but I think for most
of the population people are like oh why
don't you force them to like I talk with
some people and they're like what about
like Banning porn or Banning you know
whatever right like would that force
people to do this and it's like look or
Banning Social Media right
the cultural groups and people who
aren't resistant to the existing
pressures in this world that are
sterilizing them
uh unfortunately they're just kind of a
lost cause what we need to do is we need
to find the few groups that have found a
way to make themselves resistant to this
and sort of nurture them
um so that they can survive through this
period and then end up thriving which is
why we focus on things like trying to
it's it's not like we're it's not like
humans are
um well it depends on your view of free
will I suppose but we're not exactly
deterministic beings right if we're able
to nudge the culture in a way to get
people to change their behavior you know
people I had Pete the singer on the show
yesterday Peter Singer managed to impact
so many people's lives through animal
Liberation that wouldn't have done that
without him nudging them in that way
there is status that was associated with
being vegan therefore people started
doing it they were also bought into this
philosophy that underpinned it I I'm a
club promoter by trade right I run
nightclubs for my entire career and with
that I understand the power of Trends
and mimesis and I'm just thinking at the
moment there is a mimetic trend about
like motherhood's lame or dangerous or
Freedom restricting
changing that
Trend technology seems something that
could be quite a high leverage
opportunity yeah Delta you changed your
mind on this and I'm remembering
conversations because this is actually a
debate I've had with my wife and she's
changed my mind before but I forgot
um which is I think well she would argue
a core aspect of our advocacy if we can
is to get it modeled in in television
shows and in other types of popular
media uh that having lots of kids is a
high status thing
um the the big fear I have is I'm just
really afraid of people having kids
because it helps their status I I would
like it if it's like a yes and thing but
no matter what when you make something a
status thing there's going to be a group
of kids that are brought into the world
only because of the way they augment the
parent's status and and that means that
their parents are gonna be narcissists
and they're gonna be pretty but but
you're right I mean hopefully we can
move culture in a way that doesn't just
Target the narcissist and then it's more
holistic yeah so yeah we're about to get
on to talking about another third rail
of your uh approach to sort of embryo
screening and genetic selection and
stuff but do you see it it
almost like
for one of a better word like a breeding
experiment that we have not an
experiment but a a breeding future that
we have with humans where there are
going to be particular cohorts that
continue There are going to be
particular cohorts that don't given that
a good chunk of our behavior is
determined by our genes the type of
people that continue to reproduce will
have a particular genetic predisposition
which in the future means that we're
going to nudge the entire human races
genetic predisposition in one direction
are we in the middle of a breeding
experiment and are humans facing
extinction I'd say it's a cultural
experiment because
that's being changed is culture and the
dependent variable that we're measuring
is their ability to have kids so breed
but also maintain those kids within that
social group
um so if the kids just leave or they
don't like their lifestyle as a child
you know you can't just give a kid a
terrible childhood that they're not
going to continue that cultural group
um so and there has to be this is
actually a really interesting phenomenon
um here review look at countries that
are poorer but also have really low
fertility rates typically the common
thing across those countries is that
there is very low amounts of hope this
is why China has such a low fertility
rate
um because uh people within China this
is where the we are the last generation
meme comes from they're like what am I
just having kids so the government can
use them like there's no more like
social Mobility here or something like
this and I think it's why when you're
looking at a cultural group like Jews in
Israel there's such a high fertility
rate as there is a high level of
cultural hope within that cultural group
they feel like when they have kids
they're not just you know Grist for the
grindstone they can move up within the
culture even if they're in a low status
position
um so I would agree with everything
you're saying and I'm really excited for
this experiment
I imagine that the discussions around
climate are just another really
pernicious sort of
convincing Factor about why people
shouldn't have kids not only are you
contributing to the the burning of
fossil fuels not only are you going to
increase greenhouse gases which are
going to kill all of these other animals
but the life that your child is going to
have on this planet is also going to be
filled with fumes and gray skies and
it's going to be toxic and whatever yeah
yeah okay so the incentives but this is
I was gonna say this is also just the
latest apocalyptic cult in the U.S you
know and it's not going to be the last
one you know we keep having if the U.S
is dotted by anything it's it's dotted
by uh sort of apocalypticism
um and and fears the U.S actually Jewish
and Christian Traditions more generally
are dotted by this
um and I think the next one we're going
to see is AI why would you have kids
when AI is going to kill us all you know
um it's just a cycle and it keeps going
and you do know that there's people
there's people watching this right now
that are saying well what about you two
you two are just saying that it's a
birth rate decline apocalypse you're the
same Cassandra is that you're accusing
everyone else would be well because I I
would say that um uh I I do argue that
things are going to get worse but I
don't argue they're going to kill us all
I think if you look at real climate
change data it says which I believe the
I think it's going to get worse a lot of
suffering is going to happen because of
it but it's not going to kill us all
that climate message hasn't done as well
as spreading as you know Greta
thornberg's in one of your recent
podcasts everyone's going to be dead in
five years due to the climate AI is
going to massively change what it means
to be human
um it could even cause some major
catastrophes but it's not going to turn
us all into goo
um and so I think that there is it's
right to say that we in the world have
actual things to be afraid of there's
going to be actual systemic shifts but I
think that's different than just
apocalypticism and being like we're all
gonna die no need to think about the
future you know Harold Camping style
right
um okay so the millerist movement
getting on to what you did with your
children we've discussed what the world
should do how we should move forward
some of the challenges some of the
reasons that people don't what is the
unique process that you went through
with your wife
so
so this is spicy
um what we did is we did full genetic
sequencing of our embryos and we use
those genetic sequencings to inform the
order in which we implanted the embryos
so why did we do this well you have to
do uh uh biopsies of embryos anyways
often to determine if they're half late
or not not everyone does this but most
people do it's a normal thing you do
when you're doing IVF we had to do IVF
anyway because my wife uh was unable to
get pregnant naturally
um due to you know having depression
when she was younger which caused her to
develop uh anorexia which meant that she
doesn't like menstruate naturally and
she she actually would was trans women
she often does like competition to see
who has to take more hormones
um to to be a a woman
um and and so uh
you know she she has to do all of this
stuff to to have kids so I had to do IVF
anyway we had to do the biopsies anyway
and now is genetic screening data we
could go through that and her mom died
slowly of cancer and so we were able to
look at that you know she suffered from
major depressive disorder which also has
genetic links so we were able to look at
these things and say well I mean if we
can choose to lower the probability that
our kids have to deal with these genetic
conditions
um like would we lower that probability
like to me people are like yeah but
people will make fun of you on Twitter
if you do this it's like yeah okay my
kid comes to me and they're like Dad I
really you know want to kill myself
right now or have migraines that was
another thing we selected against uh you
could have selected against this and you
didn't because people were gonna make
fun of you on Twitter like I and this is
just our cultural group so people try to
connect this with Eugenics but Eugenics
the definition of eugenics is very clear
it's the belief that there's good and
bad genes and that the good genes should
be distributed maximally throughout
society which is sort of the anticism We
believe We believe every family every
cultural unit has beliefs about good and
bad genes right like our family doesn't
want our kids to get cancer but that
reproductive Choice should always be in
the hands of individual families and
individual cultural groups and that it
should never be enacted if anything I
would say that it's Eugenics for the
government to come and tell my family
the genetic choices we should make
because it views sort of pure unaltered
human DNA as the superior form of
humanity like they're actually saying we
need genetic Purity and humanity and
you're tainting the genetic purity of
the human species by like selecting
things I don't know to me that sounds
much more Eugenics than me being like I
don't want my kids to get cancer and
this is something many cultural groups
have done over time like Orthodox Jews
have to do this with taste acts some
black communities have to do this with
sickle cell like it's also like an
anti-semitic and racist position to call
this sort of genetic selection in this
sort of reproductive Choice
um uh uh Eugenics
um
so I think that that
um we do support and I think now here's
the thing that's the nice way to put all
of this but then let's go big or go home
let's be controversial here right so
what happens if we really hold this
position in the future well when we say
our foundation's goal is to preserve and
increase human diversity a lot of people
miss the and increase human diversity
part because as soon as families have
these choices a lot of people think
families are all going to choose the
same thing you know like I love it
people like I think everyone gonna
choose like uh a white you know a buff
child and it's like no no like blind
families aren't going to choose like
little Aryan kids or something what are
you out of your mind everyone's going to
choose things that optimize for their
cultural Traditions value system and
we're entering into this Grand
experiment where some of those value
systems will prove to be more
efficacious than other value systems
right now people are like oh you could
select right here we didn't select
direct you but you could theoretically
select for IQ and we might do it in the
future
um but IQ is such a like a a bad metric
because we're in the early days of this
technology eventually uh IQ will be 80
different things are you optimizing for
creativity are you optimizing for in the
same way you don't just optimize for
strengths you optimize for agility you
optimize for lean muscle you optimize
for like this type of muscle fiber
versus this type of muscle fiber and we
will see this blossoming I hope of human
diversity uh uh at a level that makes
our existing ethnic diversity looked
right
um and and subcultures will be very
intolerant to this new diversity uh but
I'm excited for it I'm excited for it
because I think that when we have a new
perspective when we have uh new ways of
doing things new cultural optimization
uh we get something uh more beautiful
and one of the the core focuses of our
foundation is trying to get the cost of
this technology as low as possible and a
lot of people they hear about this
technology and they go oh it must cost a
fortune I mean theoretically it doesn't
really you're looking looking at genome
sequencing which we've gotten
tremendously cheap and then once the
genome is sequenced
um you're just comparing it to a data
table so uh right now you know if you
did this at the state level it would be
tremendously inexpensive to do
um and you know you could do this for
like 50 cents a family and maybe like
fifty dollars per egg that's sequenced
and when you compare this to the cost of
IDF that is like nothing
um uh and many states are already
supporting IVF like the UK like Israel
um so uh to say that this technology
could be widely available is not a
irresponsible thing to claim at all and
I'm really excited for it
can you see why some people would feel
uncomfortable or feel that this is a
controversial technology to start using
to be able to select for particular
traits that a child would have
yeah I mean I I see that when the
problem is that it's controversial it's
except in every specific instance it's
controversial to your selecting that
your kids don't get cancer it's
your kids don't get major depressive
disorder and if you stop me and my kid
ended up committing suicide are you at
all to blame for that do you take any
responsibility and then people are like
well this technology isn't foolproof it
doesn't 100 prevent those things and
that's like you know one of these uh
religious extremists who don't want to
do blood transfusions being for their
kid you know when their kids dying or
something like well blood transfusion
doesn't always work it's like well so
what you're giving your kid a chance
smoking during pregnancy doesn't always
cause your child to have tons of
deformities but it's probably not
advised yeah
and I support the cultural groups that
don't want to use this they may be right
in the long term you know humanity is an
experiment right they may be right I may
be wrong and the future will prove which
group is right and wrong and we might
turn out that all of these decisions
we're making they don't end up making
any difference right and all we're using
this technology for right now is to
order our eggs now suppose somebody was
like oh yeah but I just want to create
tons of embryos and choose the best
embryos right and this is where I think
you get the the genuine what do you mean
sorry what do you mean when you say
order your eggs
oh it's the choice uh it determines the
the
um eggs we choose first but we still
hope to use all of our embryos
um not eggs embryos um but uh uh so it's
not like we're saying this human gets to
exist or this human doesn't get to exist
because of their genes but I mean
functionally eventually because my wife
has a C-section with every pregnancy
they're probably eventually going to
take it out to some extent we are doing
that
um but uh I can understand like when
people say
every human embryo is a life and you
shouldn't be playing these games that's
the moral argument against what we're
doing that I think holds the most water
uh the way that I look at that argument
is to say
um well IVF generally which needs you
know you need to discard some eggs off
and if you're going to do IVF in any
sort of economically sustainable way uh
it requires you discarding embryos and
it expands the human fertility window so
to me from my cultural's perspective
every human I decide not to have like if
somebody was like okay pick up this pin
and a human doesn't exist in the future
I'll decide not to have a human if you
pick up this pin then I have
functionally killed that human
um and and so I can understand why like
Catholic groups and stuff like that
would look at what we're doing and say
that well I think that the humanity only
starts at like sperm production or at
the production of an embryo and so I get
that argument it's just not my cultural
practice and I hope that they can at
least understand the spirit with which
we're doing this which is to you know
maximize the number of Offspring we have
and increase their quality of life
if all that you're doing is playing
around with the order that of the
embryos that you have
why does the order matter
well because we likely won't be able to
use all of them I mean really okay but
that's the same like choosing the order
is the same as discarding right yeah
it's probably functionally the same but
I mean again
um I just don't know how I can explain
to my kid oh yeah you got cancer because
I decided not to do this when it was
Johnny anomaly on the show about two
months ago and I love the guy yeah he
really he really sort of opened my eyes
to this and and the most compelling
argument that I heard was as soon as you
concede that um let's say the testing
that some Jewish groups Ashkenazi Jews I
think go through uh to ensure that they
don't partner up with yeah partner up
with somebody that is going to give
their child something that's awful uh
the same thing occurs within other
groups and then roll the clock forward a
tiny little bit and you say if we can
select to avoid really really reliably
heritable cancer that is just every
single woman all the way back for as
long as I can research it has always had
some form of cancer as soon as we can
select for that to not happen
you open the door to say well okay
what's the difference between that and
selecting for someone that's a little
bit more conscientious because
conscientiousness is associated with a
improved outcomes in life what about
somebody that's got not going to have
depression what about somebody that's
not going to have anxiety what about
somebody that's blah blah blah like as
soon as you open the door to not having
something negative you also then look
start to get into selecting toward uh
positive traits too is there a line that
gets thrown in the sand for you with
regards to this no I believe every
family should be able to make their own
reproductive choices
um and when we we talk about things like
IQ absolutely right if you look at this
really rough Stitch thing we have now
why IQ that I hope we can break apart
into a bunch of different things and get
much more specific ways right now I mean
this is correlated with lower rates of
rape lower rates of incarceration lower
rates of I mean raping other people
lower rates of murdering other people
like there are there are real reasons
why um you know you you may select for
this and I love when people are like oh
that's unethical and I'm like we live in
a culture today where it is normal to
dope your kids with amphetamines so that
they score slightly higher on
standardized tests where people do these
little things where they're like what
would I get for two points of IQ and and
yet uh the fact that you could make a
selection here is is off the table but
we also need to consider that eventually
other species we're gonna have to do
this and this is something that people
just aren't talking about so if you look
at
okay dysgenic pressures so historically
like 50 of humans died you know in
childhood or early in their lifehood or
something like that right
um and this prevented a lot of the
diseases that we see in our society
today as we get better at things like
C-section and keeping kids alive and
stuff like that we're going to see an
increasing number of heretical diseases
that previously would have been selected
out of humanity so you really only get
two choices before every human is just a
walking ball of cancer either you start
selecting humans before they're born or
with three choices or you start
completely editing and writing humans I
think maybe there you can get into even
more morality or you start selecting
humans after they're born or I guess you
can just enter this future where
everyone's like this walking cancer
Golem
um uh of all of these things that
previously would have been selected out
but our medical technology I think that
the most ethical Choice there long term
is probably to make these selections
before uh you know the the the the cells
really begin to replicate
in your eyes is there anything different
ethically between
rolling the dice of which sperm is going
to get there first with which egg at
which
particular time during the year's bunch
of cycles and selecting let's say that
you were able to do uh selection somehow
that didn't involve discarding eggs
because that that would be a difference
as far as you're concerned is there
anything different about parents
going out of their way to choose the
kind of Life traits person
that is going to come out as opposed to
just saying we roll the dice when it
happens it happens and with the
combination that happens is what the
child is going to get
well I mean we as a society have been
doing this for a while I mean if you
consider that sort of thing you know
Eugenics then not allowing brothers and
sisters to marry as Eugenics because you
know the reason presumably we have those
losses it leads to negative genetic
outcomes
um again I just go back to I'd say that
reproductive Choice should always be at
the level of the family and as soon as
the state or an outside force says that
a family can make these genetic choices
and can't make these genetic choices
that is the core of what Eugenics is
because you were saying people born of
these genetic choices are somehow
genetically morbid or or or like uh uh
some sort of a monstrosity and and then
what do you do what they're a second
class citizen I don't know I just don't
think there's any way where you can
begin to police families genetic choices
that doesn't turn into the the most evil
of eugenics
do you think that there's an ethical
difference between selecting embryos and
going in there and actually manipulating
genes and tinkering with stuff directly
yeah I think in a lot of people's mind
there is a difference but I think that
again this should be a cultural choice
um I think that every parent should have
the choice to to make the it's always
funny when people they say oh heliana's
wife think that we're they're like
genetically Superior I'm like we're the
ones editing our genes like we think we
are the least genetically Superior of
anyone we are editing our genes jumping
through the Hoops to try and make them
as viable as possible yeah exactly yeah
so is one final thing you know to tie
the two things that we've spoken about
today together
a lot of people are told about the
miracle that is IVF
um there are some concerns I think that
maybe women and men are overly reliant
on it to believe that it can extend
their fertility window out essentially
indefinitely ivg which may actually end
up doing this maybe we'll we'll see I'm
a fan you want to talk about what ivg is
[__] it tell everybody what ivg is and
tell them it tell them it in a very
accessible way because Johnny taught me
it and I I don't I couldn't recite it so
teach it as if you're teaching it to a
golden retriever ivg basically means
that you can create eggs and firm for
himself so it means that 2
to a kid that's biologically theirs but
it also means you can do fancier things
like you could have a poly couple of
like 13 people and they could have a kid
that is biologically owl of theirs it
basically allows you to I mean in the
simplest form it's just again from
anyone but this is really cool because
it means you know if you're older
um you know you can have kids that are
that are healthier and a lot of people
are having kids when they're older
um but then you know you combine this
with artificial wombs who we're close on
that technology too that completely like
when we're talking about cultural
changes and technological and cultural
solutions to technological and cultural
problems a lot of them are going to look
like ivg a lot of them are going to look
like artificial wounds what we may find
is one of the solutions to the current
collapsing birth rates is like gay the
Triads or something like that right or
or
um poly cities or like I'm not saying
that these things will work you know but
uh if any of these sorts of cultural
groups want to survive into the future
uh they're gonna have to find ways to
make uh themselves raising kids and
keeping their culture alive work um and
so I'm very excited to see how these
Technologies expand options for people
and expand the diversity of cultures
that are possible because there's many
more creative people than me out there
who might find even more exciting ways
to to raise families and increase the
cultural diversity of our space just
going back to the conversation about IVF
for the people that haven't been through
it or don't know somebody that has been
through it what's the experience like
it's it's painful I used to ask my wife
I've seen these sharks
right into the butt I don't know how she
handles it and she does this as a
routine we have a kid a year she wants
to keep doing this for like 10 years I
don't she is a tough
like
um but it is painful I I this this woman
was a woman who worked through her first
pregnancy she went to the hospital she
was taking sales calls while she was
having contractions
back to work within five days the level
of pain she felt when getting egg
extractions and stuff like that was
higher or not higher than pregnancy but
I mean it was hard like she is not
somebody who complains about pain she
doesn't complain about the shots but the
egg extractions they really hurt and I
know that because she wouldn't she
wouldn't mess around with that stuff uh
so what I can say is it's a it's a
painful process but if you see kids as
like your mandate in life for me not
having kids is the equivalent of suicide
or something like that
um it's just not an option for me
um and I I'm glad that my wife you know
I'd love if you had her on sometimes
she's a she's a weird woman
um but really fun
um she sees things similar to I do and
so it's just not even something we would
consider we're gonna do everything we
can and we tried to conceive naturally
for like five years and it just wasn't
in the cards and I think increasingly
what families are going to realize is uh
it's really hard to get pregnant these
days humans are becoming infertile as a
species we're becoming infertile and
you're and when you look at things like
artificial wombs they may be one of our
only shots uh because when we hear when
I hear women who have these complicated
pregnancy when I hear stillbirths oh my
God if your wife has carried a kid or
you've carried a cane when you think of
a baby dying in that last trimester and
you know that with stuff like artificial
wounds we could lower the probability of
that it just breaks your heart and you
would want to do anything you can to
accelerate the pace of this technology
Malcolm Collins ladies and gentlemen
dude I I find all of this discussion a
combination of harrowing inspiring and
interesting uh so for the people who
want to find out more about the stuff
that you do and keep up to date with
your work where should they go so uh our
book series The fragment to Sky series
of pragmatist guy to crafting religion
is the most relevant to this
conversation it's on Amazon it's for 99
cents the ebook
um Twitter account Simone H Collins
um or just you know search Simona
Malcolm Collins on Twitter uh we have a
joint account because I hate using
Twitter
um and we're recently starting up our
YouTube and podcast
um uh we just uploaded the first episode
of starting it back up today which is uh
Simona Malcolm Collins based Camp
um so uh we're hoping that that's fun
I'd love to have you on some time if
we're able to get enough followers to be
worth your time
Malcolm I appreciate you thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace